[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
Trinidad y Tobago es un archipiélago en
el sur del Mar Caribe situado entre
Venezuela y las antillas su población se
calcula en un millón y medio de personas
y un 5% de los habitantes son creyentes
del islam la tercera religión del país
entre 2013 y 2016 más de 130 trinitarios
se sumaron a las filas de la
autodenominado estado islámico
proporcionalmente a su población
Trinidad y Tobago es uno de los países
con más combatientes en el grupo
yihadista desde la caída del estado
islámico 90 ciudadanos de esta nación de
los cuales 56 son niños están detenidos
en campamentos en Siria sin esperanzas
de poder regresar a su país el gobierno
aplaza su repatriación oficialmente por
razones de seguridad interna
veamos el reportaje de ciril charpentier
y Damián
[Música]
Hace cuatro años la vida de rajima gira
en torno a las escasas noticias que
recibe de su hermana
la hermana de rajima y sus cinco hijos
están detenidos en el campamento de Rush
en Siria
Todas las semanas mi hermana nos envió
un mensaje de voz usa el teléfono del
campamento
mi sobrina también se emociona y quiere
mandarnos un mensaje
en 2014 su hermana se fue de Trinidad a
Siria más de 130ses se sumaron a las
filas del autodenominado estado islámico
entre 2013 y 2016
en 2019 estuvo presente Durante los
bombardeos que ocurrieron en el asedio
de baús último bastión del grupo
yihadista
logró huir de la ciudad pero rápidamente
fue detenida por las fuerzas de la
coalición
Eso fue hace cuatro años
ha estado ahí desde hace tanto tiempo
que ha empezado a desarrollar problemas
mentales creo que sufre de estrés
postraumático su mente está en otra
parte sí ya no sabe quién es pierde la
memoria ni siquiera reconoce a sus
propios hijos
preocupada por la salud de su hermana
decidió hacer todo lo posible para
traerla de vuelta a Trinidad
su madre que quiere mantener el
anonimato no pierde la esperanza de
volver a ver a su hija y a sus nietos
compró este juguete para el menor
Y estos diademas para su nieto
sigue comprando cosas
las guarda para mi hermana y sus hijos
le he dicho que tiene que parar
porque no se está haciendo nada
al igual que la hermana y los sobrinos
de rajimacán muchas mujeres y niños
viven prisioneros
actualmente 90 trinitenses estarían
encerrados en esos campamentos en Siria
entre ellos habría 56 menores de los
cuales 33 habrían nacido ahí el gobierno
aplaza su repatriación oficialmente por
razones de seguridad interna con el 5%
de la población creyente el islam es la
tercera religión de Trinidad faud abu
bar es uno de los líderes de llamadad
esta organización promueve los aspectos
políticos y sociales de la religión fue
fundada por su padre yasin abu bar
conocido por haber organizado un golpe
de estado en 1990
Durante los años 70 la llamada almend
estuvo en el centro de las luchas
anticoloniales de las comunidades
afrocaribeñas
[Música]
fue una época en la que las personas
despertaron y tomaron conciencia en el
Caribe
el movimiento black power fomentó que
los africanos reconocieran sus raíces y
sus religiones de origen
muchas personas retornaron no decimos se
convirtieron si no retornaron al islam
[Música]
esa misma ideología llevó algunos de sus
compatriotas a seguir la propaganda del
grupo estado islámico
se fueron para encontrar algo mejor se
fueron en busca de una utopía la
creación de un estado islámico
querían hacer parte de algo bueno de
algo positivo de algo islámico
al igual que
actualmente varios líderes religiosos
minimizan la inclinación violenta de
esos combatientes
[Música]
un modo limón
es un antiguo miembro de la llamada
almen
participó en el golpe de estado
organizado por yasinaboard y reconoce
haber tenido vínculos con al qaeda
la información que circulaba en esa
época no era el tipo de información que
habría impedido que las personas se
fueran
nunca disuadimos a la gente que se
quería ir
sin embargo desde su creación el grupo
terrorista estado islámico ha promovido
la violencia
esta mujer padeció El Terror del grupo
yihadista
para mantener su anonimato se hace
llamar solange
habían muchos bombardeos y muertos la
policía del estado islámico era muy
estricta
y sus castigos siempre eran muy severos
entonces había que obedecer
siempre había que obedecer
sino podías terminar en la cárcel
o ser ejecutado
después de haber conseguido escapar
regresó a Trinidad con sus dos hijos
con ayuda de su abogado inició un
proceso judicial para que su hijo nacido
en Siria pueda obtener la nacionalidad
dice que su marido la engañó le hizo
creer que había conseguido un contrato
como futbolista en Turquía Pero al final
terminaron en Siria y solange se vio
sometida a la ley de la autodenominado
estado islámico
le dije a mi marido que regresáramos
pero se opuso
me llevó a los tribunales porque si no
quieres quedarte significa que eres una
espía y uno de los tipos me dijo que
podía cortarme la cabeza que podían
matarme por eso
entonces empecé a obedecer sus reglas
y a pensar en un plan para escaparme
finalmente logró huir y llegar hasta una
zona controlada por las fuerzas turcas
refugiada en un campamento pudo ponerse
en contacto con su consulado
por su historia y las pruebas de su
evasión fue reconocida como víctima de
laesh
la repatriaron en 2016 pero su regreso a
la vida normal fue difícil
dejé de usar mi velo porque me
discriminaban cuando volví
creo que es injusto
porque todo el mundo comete errores
y a veces ni siquiera es culpa de uno
la mayoría de las mujeres que conocí
estaban ahí por culpa de sus esposos
ni siquiera sabían A dónde estaban yendo
decidió dedicarse a luchar por la suerte
de esas mujeres esta antigua diputada
está ayudando a ragem Khan para que su
hermana pueda volver al país juntas
llaman la atención sobre las difíciles
condiciones de vida de las mujeres y
niños detenidos en Siria el menor de los
niños que está ahí tiene apenas tres
años nació en el campamento lo único que
ese niño conocido es la vida de una
tienda de campaña el gobierno de
Trinidad y Tobago ha estado trabajando
desde 2018 en una nueva ley
antiterrorista con el objetivo de
repatriar a sus ciudadanos
garantizando al mismo tiempo la
seguridad del país cinco años después
esa legislación aún no se ha concretado
si consideramos las ventajas y
desventajas Sí hay cuestiones de
seguridad interna que hay que tener en
cuenta
pero debemos optar por las ventajas
humanitarias no por las cuestiones de
seguridad para todas esas personas las
condiciones de vida en los campamentos
son atroces no hay un sistema de
saneamiento no hay viviendas decentes
tienen que vivir en el suelo entre las
ratas
hay muchas enfermedades y el agua está
contaminada
gran parte de los trinitenses
prisioneros en los campamentos sirios no
pueden obtener un documento de identidad
sin pasaporte no pueden volver a su país
nafesa Mohamed asesora a las familias en
sus procesos judiciales actualmente hay
tres demandas en curso contra el estado
de Trinidad y Tobago Hay personas
responsables que son capaces de cerrar
los ojos ante las dificultades de esta
gente no eso es inaceptable la comunidad
musulmana contribuye desde hace años el
desarrollo de este país
somos capaces de vivir en paz y de
trabajar juntos mano a mano
se trata de mujeres y niños que están en
una situación vulnerable y necesitan
protección
en 2019 el regreso de los dos hijos
se convirtió en un evento mediático
tras ser secuestrados por su padre que
se marchó para sumarse al estado
islámico Felicia quedó separada de ellos
y había perdido toda la esperanza de
volver a verlos pero después de una
operación humanitaria financiada por el
líder Pink Floyd logró llevarlos de
regreso a Trinidad
desde que volvieron lo único que querían
era estar a mi lado querían volver a
estar con su madre
he tenido que recuperar el tiempo que
perdí con ellos hasta que vuelvan a
poner los pies en la tierra y se
[Música]
recuperens quisiera que sus hijos sean
El ejemplo de una reintegración exitosa
han visto muchas cosas muchos cadáveres
cuerpos destrozados es algo realmente
traumático para unos niños
lo único que quieren es poder tener una
vida normal ser como los demás que no lo
señalen ni se burlen de ellos por algo
que no escogieron
tras su llegada el gobierno creó una
comisión encargada de los regresos de
Siria
Durante un año los hijos de felissa
perkins tuvieron un acompañamiento
psicológico
pero ahora han dejado de recibir
asistencia y el trabajo de la comisión
está detenido
desde hace cuatro años ningún trinitense
ha sido repatriado hasta creo que el
gobierno realmente podría hacer más para
que regresen al país y ayudarlos a que
vuelvan a subir anterior porque lo único
que quieren es crecer con normalidad a
pesar de nuestras múltiples solicitudes
el gobierno de Trinidad y Tobago no
contestó a nuestras preguntas
según human right Swatch más de 40.000
extranjeros seguirían retenidos en los
campamentos en Siria
cerca de la mitad tendría menos de 12
años
hasta aquí reporteros a la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]